hola buenas tardes la jornada electoral
transcurre con mucha tranquilidad y
grandes colas que se desviven en los
colegios electorales de todo el país
estamos cerca de 1 aproximadamente a una
cuadra y vemos colas con grandes
aglomeraciones de gente personas que han
tenido que esperar hasta dos horas para
ejercer su derecho a sufragio y una cola
que se alarga durante varias cuadras así
que los chilenos hacen esperan bajo un
sol de justicia hay bastantes grados hoy
para poder ejercer este derecho a voto
en estas elecciones históricas y muy
importantes para el futuro del país y
precisamente usted lo dijo que estas
elecciones son históricas y esto es
porque se va a tener en cuenta el papel
que tenga el próximo presidente en la
implementación de la nueva constitución
pero también se van a elegir diputados y
parte de los senadores porque serán
importante ellos
así ese se renueva completamente la
cámara de diputados- y se elige
senadores en 9 de las 16 regiones del
país esto es muy importante para los
balances políticos que podrían verse
cambiados la derecha tiene las
esperanzas puestas en el senado en
retener al menos un tercio o más de
senadores en ese órgano importante por
ejemplo como vimos la semana pasada con
la acusación constitucional que fue
impedida porque un tercio de los
senadores eran más de un tercio de los
senadores eran oficialistas y lo mismo
ocurre en la cámara de diputados que
podría volver a tener un balance de un
tercio un tercio un tercio de fuerzas es
decir que ninguno podría obtener la
mayoría total y obligaría por tanto a
acuerdos entre las distintas coaliciones
una cámara de diputados que podría verse
mucho más fragmentada y donde también
hay muchos más candidatos tanto a
senadores como a diputados que en otras
elecciones